Edge of Eternities is set in the void
between the multiverse and the blind
eternities. And now with the Eldrazi
involved, things are about to get wild.
We haven't seen the full spoilers yet,
but it's already clear this set plays
heavily with the exile. This zone, once
called removed from the game, has become
Magic's sandbox of weird ideas. It's
where wizards dumps mechanics that don't
quite fit anywhere else. But we've hit a
point where there are enough Exile
payoffs to build real powerful decks
around it. I am Jyn and this is Next
Level Commander. And today's video is a
deep dive into playing with the Exile
Zone mechanics, synergy, powerhouse
cards, and three unique decks that each
tackle exile in a different way. If you
enjoy this kind of content, please like
and subscribe. It helps me know what
videos are landing with you. So,
interacting with Exile is not quite as
powerful as the graveyard. I mean, it
should never be. or we have some serious
problems with game design. But we do
have some pretty unique advantages. For
example, they've printed some
hyperefficient hate for graveyard
strategies, which of course is needed. A
mere bajukabog or heavens forbid resting
peace would ruin turns of setup for our
graveyard bros. But exile, you just
can't hit on exile. I mean, once
something is plotted or foretold, it's
even safer than being in your hand.
They're not going away until you cast
it. Although I know this guy exists, but
yeah, just blow him up with feed the
swarm or something and we're rolling
again. You can't say the same about
losing your graveyard, can you? So,
while not being quite as efficient,
Exile is actually the safest place in
the entire game to accumulate resources.
Exile is nothing. You can't mess with
nothingness. The first legend that got
people looking this way is probably
Prosper the Homebound, and he is
freaking popular. The abilities seem
simple, but when you see a Prosper deck
play out, it's just ridiculous value.
But in the past couple of years, we got
a ton of other options that are
interesting and also powerful. Before we
get to the decks though, we'll start off
with some of the mechanics and
synergies. Here's a clip where I was
talking about Prosper, Impulse, Draw,
Cascade, Discover, Plot, Forell, Magnus,
Adventure, Suspend, Rebound, and
Ragavan. Am I missing any? I'm sure
there are a bunch of mechanics that I
missed. You can get just about every
utility that interacts with the exile
zone, be it card draw, removal, board
wipes, or ramp. And these exile
mechanics can mix and match to great
effect. I mean, imagine having six face
up cards in exile, all from different
effects along with a pile under void
counters, one with collection counters,
and don't forget hit counters. Your
opponents should probably concede at
that point. Cascade and Discover are my
personal favorites among them because
you can chain them into each other
getting ridiculous triggers from the
payoff cards like this one. Just look at
this card. Holy crap. But more on the
spicy payoffs later. Forell is also
excellent because unlike most other
similar mechanics, foretold cards are
hidden and will keep your opponents
guessing. Another perk of the Forell
cards is that many of them have special
effects when cast from exile. Delayed
blast fireball, for example, gets a
massive boost. The idea is you get a
much bigger spell if you spend the extra
mana and go through the trouble to
foretell, but not in our decks because
as long as we manage to cast this from
exile with cascade, for example, we get
the five damage. Similar effects can be
seen on these new Final Fantasy designs
and I think it's an awesome payoff.
Another really interesting one is
hideway. Some of these lands are
actually sweet, but they also put
hideway onto nonland cards.
Ever cold earth sign is a card I've
always wanted to play but can't find a
deck for it until today. And of course,
we have to talk about warp from Edge of
Eternities. It's a strange mechanic, but
these cards are just so cool. It's like
they warp in and out of reality. What's
the flavor? This girl just drops a quick
silent dips or this guy who guards the
door for a second and peace out drops
all his weapons and armor. Uh then
there's this. Yeah, not sure what's the
lore on this one, but anyways, some of
these are enter or leave the battlefield
effects that you can get once from warp
and later pay full cost for the entire
package, while others can act as mini
spells. I mean, sometimes you don't have
enough mana to make a doubler and tokens
in the same turn. No problems. We can
get doubling for a turn at a discount.
And same with ETB abilities. These
designs are just fascinating. Can't wait
to mix all these into our decks later on
in the video. Now, enough about
mechanics. We're talking about specific
cards that are bonkers at enabling
casting from exile. Let's start with
italies. These are some of the bombiest
creatures in all of Magic and in an
exile matters deck, they are even more
ridiculous. Remember this thing? Also,
the main demon from Duskorn, Valgo. This
is sweet. Just go around the table once
and we'll probably get plenty of gas.
And if our opponents won't comply, we
can always do it ourselves. Opposition
agent is an all-star, of course. Needs
no introduction. But Ray, Ty extractor,
and the gantis can also steal piles upon
piles from our opponents. And while
we're on the topic of robbery, I prefer
the outrageous variety. Or just pay one
more mana and get to cast them all for
free. Seems good. Also, they've been
printing removals that steal creatures
for us to use. Even a freaking board
wipe. But let's move away from black. Is
it also has all these cards that allow
us to spam the cast from exile triggers.
Misix's mastery and Emato's augury, for
example. And they're so mana efficient.
I know it's weird to say that about an
eight mana spell, but the kind of impact
they can bring in the late game is
disproportional. Also got to mention the
Luvian primordial because it's not often
looked at as an exile staple is more
like a staple staple. Yeah, the card is
nuts and even better with what we're
doing here. Also worth noting if you
exile something and copy it from exile,
they count as being cast from exile. I'm
pretty sure, but I was also pretty sure
with things in my lens video and we know
how that went. So, if you're a judge and
I'm wrong here, just make a comment.
I'll ping it. And of course, how can we
forget about possibility storm?
Everything comes in from exile. Now,
this might be a bit too chaotic for some
groups, but the ones that embrace it
will be eating good with some of the
value engines that we'll cover later.
And the impulse draws, of course,
Jessica's will needs no introduction. I
heard it changes games, but I'm also a
big fan of professional face breaker. It
seems like everything nowadays makes
treasures, and face breaker turns them
into exile gas. Light up the stage is
also an efficient little effect often
overlooked, especially in the more
aggressive decks. Getting the cards till
the end of your next turn makes it much
more likely that you will end up using
both cards for full value. Impulse Draw
is cool and all, but what about Impulse
Tutor? Yeah, you heard that right. Besie
the Mirror. There are just so many Exile
related effects hidden all across
Magic's history that I can't pretend to
know them all. But as long as we keep
our Exile goggles on, we'll surely find
plenty of other cool gems. And before we
stray too far from exile tutors, there's
also this big dragon. Not only does it
tutor for something into exile, it's
also a payoff that gives convulk to all
cards from exile. And this is our segue
into the payoff section. Finally, we get
to reveal the delicious cards that
reward us for all this setup. First up,
Malfni. Yes, it doesn't really matter
what mechanic or tribe you're playing.
You can never go wrong with doubling.
And because of how difficult Exile is to
work with, the payoffs are actually
sweet. I mean, look at this one. Imagine
doing this with the graveyard at four
mana. It's not happening. Only with
exile. Party thrasher 2, turning all our
creatures into manadors for spells. Not
something red usually has access to.
Keeper of secrets is one of those win
conditions when you change spells with
something like cascade. Flaming
Tyrannosaurus is a similar effect, but
on a dinosaur, so that's always an
upgrade. Also, there's this sweet
background for just two mana, which we
will be building around in one of our
decks later today. Quintorious is a
planaineswalker designed around plane
from exile and it works really well with
itself for more value and less burn
everything down. Vega is a classic
open-ended design. In blue, surge of
brilliance works beautifully with the
stormier exile decks. Extraordinary
journey is a neat little tech I really
like in blue. It's a bit like mhook
massacre too. It's fine to play as just
an enchantment, but if you have the
mana, you can also bounce some creatures
and get extra value as your opponents
recast. We also have Sage of the Beyond,
which is a fairly aggressive cost
reduction effect. And fortune teller's
talent, which is a bit slow, but you do
get incremental value as you level it
up, and eventually it becomes a
self-powering engine. Moving on, a green
savvy trader is sweet, but my favorite
here has to be Tenali Hunter. Turning
all our adventure cards into spells with
a free creature attached. And at this
point, you can see that exile payoffs
are cool, but definitely a bit limited,
especially in black and white. Although
I have no doubt we'll continue to be fed
new tools. For now, we have an
imbalance. Abundance of choices, but not
enough payoff and synergy. Fortunately
though, we chose the right format. This
imbalance can be patched to a large
extent with our commander choices.
Prosper goes without saying, and for the
complete opposite colors, we have Kellen
the kid. Fidor is a decent card overall,
but I feel it might not do enough to
warrant building around. But then I
thought something similar about Prosper
when it was first spoiled and we know
how that went. Doc Erlock is crazy
aggressively costed for what it does. I
mean just look at the Sage of Beyond
again for reference. But today we want
something a little more interesting.
Next up I have for you three decks that
work with the exile zone in their unique
ways. And I'm saving my favorite for the
end. First off is the background we
promised earlier. Passionate
Archaeologist with Durnan of the Yanning
Portal. This deck kind of just builds
itself. Just look at these enablers.
Scorpions, dinosaurs, and surprise, it's
now fetchne again. Duran's ability is
actually so powerful in multiplayer,
allowing us to dig and cast a creature
at a massive discount. But we can't just
rely on that once a turn, though. We're
definitely bringing in them signs,
Italy's cascading monsters. Oh, and this
one for sure. Our opponents will just be
glaring at this in awe while we pew pew
them with the background. For other
creatures and utility, we're
prioritizing ones with exile mechanics
like adventure, plot, forell, and all
that good stuff. And of course, we're
playing these cards with the From Exile
boosts. Yeah, seems fun. And I can't
wait to see more warp cards from Edge of
Eternities, and I'm sure they'll make a
payoff card or five for this mechanic.
Anyways, our next deck is for the spell
slingers. Laya, Undefeated, Slickshot.
And honestly, I couldn't quite believe
when I first saw this. For just three
mana, you get all your spells twice. I
mean, multicolored is a bit restrictive,
but the payoff is massive, giving the is
it spell slinger deck a completely
different pattern of play. In the early
stages, we're playing the typical
controlly game. I mean, the usual
counter spells and removals and certain
draw spells, we're still going to play
whether they're multicolored or not. But
whenever we get a window, we try to
sneak out a multicolored spell, get some
value, and send it to the plot. So, it's
like setting bombs all over the place
and waiting to blow them up in the end.
What these spells do honestly isn't the
most important here. It could be draw
damage. Now, keep in mind that counter
spells or something like inverse
polarity don't actually work from plot
because they can't be cast when they are
valid targets on the stack. And once we
have a critical mass of those in the
midame, we can play one of the payoff
cards and just go off. With just five
cards plotted, we'll be getting a ton of
value. With 10, we're easily looking at
straight up winning the game. And of
course, plotting won't be our only way
of storming off. There's still music
mastery, remember? Now, back to winning
the game. Let's start with a fun one.
How about storm spplitter? Let's say we
cast this and then seven spells from
plot. That's 128 copies. Probably enough
to kill a few opponents. How about
sorcerers class? Seven spells with that
is 28 damage to each opponent. Now, if
we're not ready to kill just yet, we can
store some mana and refill our hands to
continue the fight or embrace the chaos
with bonus round or this monstrosity.
I'm actually scared to recommend this
cuz I can't even resolve this card
properly when the storm count goes up.
So yeah, if you play this, don't at me.
Get your play group to help figure out
what happens. I'm sure they would love
to. Also, some honorable mentions, Ether
Flugs, Mind's Desire, Crackling,
Splinger, whatever places you the most
really or confuses your opponents the
most. Is is it isn't it it fun? Never
mind. And next up, we have our personal
favorite, Ganty Kenny Inquisitor. Now,
in this deck, we're barely playing any
of the payoffs or enablers except the
most exceptional ones like Doc Erlac.
But here, we're actually taking
advantage of the safety of the Exile
Zone. In the early game, we ramp hard
and send out small evasive creatures to
loot as much as we can. And that's all
our deck is designed to do. No win
conditions, no answers. And in the mid
to late game, we'll just be playing with
a hand of 20 to 30 cards sponsored by
our opponents and win with that. Because
again, unlike any other resource, the
exile cards we accumulate early on are
untouchable unless an opponent loses the
game, so keep them alive. And that's
pretty much the deck. Evasive creatures,
prioritizing the ones with unblockable
because our opponents will eventually
get flyers and gingerbrew because food.
Some of our ram choices will also be
interesting with rituals and one use
artifacts because we'll most likely have
three evasive creatures ready to attack
on turn three. So ideally, we have our
commander out by then. So, the ones I
almost never play in other decks,
especially not other green decks, make
their way into this one. And of course,
the traditional RAM cards to set us up
for later on. Oh, and a few GI backups.
That's it. Simple, clean, and elegant.
And there you have it. Exile once the
remove from the game zone. Now, a
fullblown strategy space at your
fingertips. This is Jyn from Next Level
Commander. Please like and subscribe and
let me know what exile commanders you're
playing. Also, which sweet tech did I
gloss over completely? There's probably
a bunch.